madame monsieur bonsoir heureux de vous
retrouver sur france 3 basse-normandie
ici en direct du village des jeux
équestres mondiaux après une journée de
relâche hier bien la compétition a pu
reprendre ce matin avec de la voltige et
du saut d'obstacles et avec des espoirs
côté français vous le verrez mais pour
commencer d'abord l'actualité dans votre
région une actualité marquée bien sûr
par la rentrée des classes une rentrée
un peu particulière à caen dans l'école
albert camus un établissement qui avait
brûlé il ya de cela un an et demi les
élèves ont pu reprendre les cours ce
matin ambiant sur place avec un sabine
daniel et loïc blache cette partie là on
a été refaite non pas parce qu'elle a
été atteinte par le feu directement
parce que le fait de côté mais elle a
été refaite parce que vania vd toutes
les fumées toutes les poussières du feu
qui est venu jusqu'ici il y avait de
tout noirci par tous visite des locaux
avec un directeur heureux ce matin la
rentrée à albert camus un petit goût de
retour les élèves de l'école vont
retrouver leurs salles de classe dans
leur quartier après un an d'absence pour
cause d'un incendie
lel qui abritait les classes primaires
avait été la plus touchée
ça durait sur une année quoi le temps de
la déconstruction puisque nous on a
déménagé sur l'école l'ancienne école
des cormorans donc on est resté une
année scolaire l'appareil les travaux
sont terminés la cet été mais pour une
question d'assurance doit refaire à
l'identique et on est très content de
retrouver des locaux qui sont aussi à
cieux si agréable comprenez c'est donc
là vraiment c'est un retour un retour
aux sources en indiens nous rentrée
scolaire en chasse une autre nouvelle
maîtresse nouvelle classe nouveau
programme beaucoup de choses restent à
découvrir
le maire de caen affine tournée
d'inspection pour constater que tout
était rentré dans le voir quant aux
rythmes scolaires joël bruneau se
déclare légaliste nous avons souhaité
effectivement avec amandine françois qui
m'accompagne ce matin ils ont créé un
adjoint en charge de l'éducation prend
le temps de la concertation avec les
enseignants les parents
les associations pour effectivement là
où c'est nécessaire revoir un certain
nombre de dispositifs au cours de
l'année enfin y réfléchir pendant
l'année scolaire 2014 2015 pour que ce
soit opérationnel pour la prochaine
rentrée
si certains sont contents de retrouver
leur école de quartier pour les cp
l'ajout de la rentrée était parfois
mitigés
voilà un grand jour pour les écoliers
donc il était précisément 336 mille cinq
cent cinquante à faire leur rentrée ce
matin dans les écoles collèges et lycées
de basse-normandie accueilli par près de
vingt mille enseignants public et privé
confondus
et qui dit rentrée dit forcément
fournitures scolaires internet progresse
bien sûr mais les grandes surfaces
restent incontournables même si
contrairement aux idées reçues on peut
faire de très bonnes affaires
ailleurs à falaise voyez le reportage de
jean baptiste papier et loïc blache pour
l'achat des fournitures scolaires
le premier réflexe du consommateur
l'hypermarché des prix annoncés
attractifs des slogans publicitaires
accrocheur pour ces acheteurs les
critères sont dans cette grande surface
et de prix c'est beaucoup moins cher
on a un choix justement plus important
donc différents prix aux différents
coachs en êtes vous bien sûr vraiment
réussi là est la question
le supermarché moins cher pour en être
certain nous avons choisi huit articles
classiques 13 ans dans un cartable
d'écolier
puis nous avons poussé la porte de sa
patrie du centre ville d achat de marque
identique deux produits sur huit coûte
finalement moins cher en papeterie à
l'exemple du papier à dessin et du stylo
bille d'un sign craint le super marché
plus compétitif
exemples les plus significatifs les
feutres ils sont trois fois moins cher
dans un cas c'est le même prix pour
concurrencer les grandes surfaces cette
papeterie membres d'un réseau national
d'achat de fournitures
elle mise sur le compte email le service
après-vente distant très difficile car
on y loue un an
autre atout la vente à l'unité nous
avons pas mal de clients qui ont acheté
comme ça en lot et qui reviennent
l'année suivante au moment de la rentrée
en 2d en bas il m'en restait 5 mais ils
sont secs je peux pas l'utiliser
donc cette année je vais acheter à
l'unité pour ça aussi c'est un facteur
d'économie en quelque sorte vous
rivaliser avec les hypers dernier
avantage incontestable de la papeterie
la vente produits introuvables et haut
de gamme et parmi les nouveautés cette
année le lycée hôtelier dif dans le
calvados ouvrait ses portes ce matin une
inauguration après plus de deux ans de
travaux installé auparavant à hérouville
saint clair le lycée rabelais aura coûté
près de 45 millions d'euros
il formera entre autres des cuisiniers
des pâtissiers ou encore des barmen
voilà 600 élèves y sont accueillis 760 à
terme certains ont pu découvrir
l'établissement aujourd'hui en même
temps que leurs enseignants gainey louis
est pas un
on en mangerait la façade de l'école
évoque une mie de pain ou comment donner
l'envié aux 600 élèves d'apprendre ici
les métiers de bouche et de l'hôtellerie
à l'intérieur on peut rêver en grand
même si tout est encore en travaux ou
emballés
l'entrée des restaurants qui va se
passer par éthique pour les la clientèle
on va avoir tout ce qu il vente à
emporter et puis de ce côté là le côté
facturation aux pêches
je vais une fois ça tombe bien l'hôtel
n'est pas encore ouvert deux trois
petites choses à terminer dans les six
chambres professionnelles mais deux
élèves jettent un coup d'oeil aux
chantiers si vous êtes à d'habitation
les anciennes chambres beaucoup plus
grand et la déco est beaucoup plus
moderne aussi il nous est vraiment
offert un outil exceptionnel ce soit au
niveau de condition de travail puisque
tout est regroupé dans un même niveau
alors que dans l'ancien bien fallu
adapter et je dirais que vu pour ma fin
de carrière c'est vraiment un très beau
cadeau qui m'est donnée de vivre jusqu'à
la retraite
en cuisine les casseroles ne sont pas
encore un peu de patience mais sont ces
merveilles de temps d'espacé de matériel
vous avez enfin pour deux élèves
portable les premières fournées de pain
devrait sortir la semaine prochaine et
petits plats dans quinze jours
vous pourrez venir les goûters
l'ouverture du restaurant de l'école
réservation obligatoire voilà l ami
chenu qui file la métaphore budgétaire
sur la façade du lycée rabelais 45
millions d'euros quand même hein on l'a
financé par le conseil régional
en bref dans l'actualité parmi les faits
divers un homme de 25 ans a été victime
d'une violente agression à vire dans la
nuit du 30 au 31 août en plein centre
ville
originaire de villers bocage la victime
a été rouée de coups par une dizaine de
personnes
il revenait de discothèque il a été
hospitalisé en soins intensifs dans un
état grave
autre grand trip coeur de l'actualité la
visite aujourd'hui dans le sud-manche
d'emmanuel macron le ministre de
l'économie tout juste nommé à la place
d'arnaud montebourg a réservé sa
première sortie pour l'entreprise a
comme un gros employeur de la région
spécialisée dans les fibres optiques
franck besnier et loïc blache g
enchantés de recevoir mon village de
roumanie merci bob un honneur pour les
premiers pas du nouvel homme fort de
bercy c'est ici à roumanie un village de
11 cents habitants dans la manche qui
emmanuel macron a donc choisi de faire
son premier déplacement en province pour
cette visite de terrain
il est accompagné de deux secrétaires
d'état au commerce et à l'industrie
numérique et repiquer et qu'on soit très
concret et moi c'est ce que je veux
toute la presse nationale est là pour
voir à l'oeuvre le nouveau ministre de
36 ans inconnu du grand public il ya
huit jours il a choisi a comme le leader
européen du câble et de la fibre optique
1300 salariés 460 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires à comme ce que si la
première coopérative de salariés du pays
était vrai on est une société
industrielle donc il faut se bat tous
les jours pour fabriquer des bons
produits pour livrer avec la meilleure
qualité le meilleur service pour honorer
nos clients parce que son client ne peut
pas vivre ça y est via leur ensuite du
tout premier point de presse
emmanuel macron invité à réagir aux
propos du ministre du travail et ce
matin sur le contrôle renforcé des
chômeurs vous êtes quand même
extraordinaire toutes et tous
on est sur le terrain pour parler de
l'entreprise française de l'économie et
vous me demandez de commenter ce que
d'autres ministres ont dit ou les
réactions d'autres membres du
gouvernement ou de l'elysée est ce que
ces ministres ont dit non mais pardon
mais je être ministre dans un
gouvernement
ça n'est pas commenter ce n'est pas
faire du bruit avec sa bouche c'est agir
et si le régler le problème de français
emmanuel macron a voulu imprimer un
style
il a ensuite déjeuné avec les salariés
un repas auquel cette fois les
journalistes n'étaient pas complets
après le cavalier macron qui devra faire
face à de nombreux obstacles
la niche venu donc pour redresser le
pays
rentrée scolaire et politique l'heure
est donc au bilan touristique le comité
régional du tourisme vient justement de
publier l'avis des professionnels du
secteur et se re août n'a pas été si
mauvais que cela
voyez cela en détail avec aurélie misery
juillet sous le soleil août sous la
pluie
du côté du ciel les deux mois d'été ont
été très contrastés mais le monde mais
on n'a pas découragé les touristes c'est
un an juge le sentiment des
professionnels du secteur
57 % d'entre eux jugent bonne la
fréquentation du mois d'août cette boue
ce pot de plus qu'en 2008
une fréquentation qui a davantage
profité aux musées qu'aux sites de plein
air grâce au 70e et aux caprices de la
météo les sites touristiques couvert ont
enregistré de fortes augmentations du
nombre d'entrées ce tourisme bas
normands restent toujours porté par une
clientèle étrangère une clientèle jugé
la hausse par 56% des professionnels du
tourisme
après les faits 70e notre région
bénéficie de l'effet jeux équestres
mondiaux dont l'impact s'est fait
ressentir dans les trois départements
bas-normands
bonsoir à toutes et à tous si vous nous
rejoignez vous êtes sur france 3
normandie toujours en direct du village
des jeux équestres mondiaux place
maintenant à l'actualité de ces jeux la
compétition florent a pu reprendre ce
matin avec l'épreuve reine le saut
d'obstacles ouais et regardez il s'est
passé plein de choses au stade michel
d'ornano pas vraiment rempli c'est vrai
mais on s'est régalé cent cinquante
trois cavaliers engagés pour cette
épreuve de vitesse qui compte à la fois
pour le concours individuel et par
équipe et c'est un irlandais bertram
allen ici à l'image qui a réalisé le
meilleur chrono mais les français ont
brillé eux aussi et notamment nos trois
champions bas normands qui figureront
c'est parmi les meilleurs mondiaux et
qui rêve de médaille regarder ça
commence ce matin avec la calvadosienne
pénélope leprévost qui va réaliser un
sans faute sur sa jument flora de
mariposa
pénélope leprévost qui reçoit la
première ovation du stade michel
d'ornano
elle prend finalement la sixième place
une super saison
et puis en début d'après midi c'est au
tour d'un nouveau calvadosien patrice
delaveau de s'élancer sur la piste du
stade d'ornano sur son cheval
orient-express qui va imprimer un train
d'enfer regarder delaveau réalise lui
aussi un parcours absolument parfait et
il prend la deuxième place en fin de
journée kevin staut le troisième
bas-normands vaslui commettre une petite
erreur qui va lui coûter cher
dommage pour kevin staut qui doit se
contenter de la 19e place
mais super prestation globale des
français qui s'empare de la première
place du classement provisoire parra qui
a écouté patrice delaveau justement le
meilleur de ses cavaliers français
c'est une épreuve qui avait vraiment
très difficile épreuve de chasse parce
que ok pour un bon classement il faut
pas non plus mettre trop dans le train
l'autre dans le rouge il reste cinq
jours de compétition
on avait très bien démarré avec simon et
pénélope qu'on savait qu'on avait une
très bonne chance de bien figurer déjà
pour pour demain pour commencer
l'épreuve par équipes mais j'ai pu
enfoncer un petit peu le clou et je
pense que tout le monde est soulagé je
pense qu'on va finir très près si c'est
pas en tête très près dans la dans le
peloton de tête donc c'est déjà une
petite bouffée d'air pour nous pour la
suite de du concours voilà on rejette le
goupil notre consultant nous a rejoint
bonsoir andré-jacques que vous étiez
directement via au coeur du stade
d'ornano vous avez commenté un cette
compétition chaude ambiance hier
l'épreuve
vraiment quelle épreuve je vous annonce
que le matin à la reconnaissance tout le
monde dit zéro c'est l'une des plus
petites épreuves d'ouverture qu'on a eu
depuis quatre ou cinq jeux mondiaux et
ça a fait énormément de foot on a plein
de favoris qui se sont effondrés non
c'est vraiment super on sait que c'est
l'épreuve de vitesse une épreuve très
important parce que finalement c'est
elle qui met les équipes en ordre de
marche pour la suite
on peut dire que les français ont fait
le travail ben aux quatre français sont
dans le top 20 si on prend le moins bien
classé c'est kevin staut qui est vous
venez d'annoncer à cause d'une faute
mais ça va lui faire que deux points
d'écart sur la pole position
donc c'est vraiment parfait l'équipe est
vraiment en position de force avant
d'attaquer l'épreuve de demain
c'est une épreuve assez technique on
appelle d'ailleurs la chasse vous
propose de revenir un petit peu sur
cette épreuve de vitesse de façon un peu
didactique avec les explications de
catherine berra et de jean michel
guillot
le stress du team france pendant le
passage de pénélope leprévost et la joie
d'une première épreuve réussie une
épreuve de vitesse à un mètre cinquante
appelé la chasse 14 obstacles dont
certains naturel à franchir sans faute
le plus vite possible
et un parcours jolie simple moderne et
toutes les difficultés mais déjà un
parcours galopant aux débuts des virages
1 2 assez compliqué une hauteur normale
au monde y met mes amis concurrents
on voit des fautes c'est le premier jour
du championnat du monde
donc effectivement ils peuvent pas
prendre tous les risques dans la chasse
les fautes sont pénalisés en seconde qui
s'ajoute au temps total du parcours une
barre qui tombe coûte 4 secondes de
pénalité en cas de refus puisque le
couple est déjà pénalisée par le temps
perdu a reçu tel obstacle
en revanche les chutes sont
éliminatoires on avait une incroyable là
ce matin des cavaliers qui sont top
niveau qui tombe des fautes des fautes
incroyable ce qui prouve bien qu'il ya
quelque chose de particulier parce que
ce championnat du monde cent cinquante
trois cavaliers étaient au départ quand
une majorité provenant de pays émergents
la difficulté de la chasse pour le chef
de piste c'est d'adapter son parcours à
tous les niveaux d'équitation c'est vrai
que c'est toujours important d'amener
des nouveaux prix dans ce sport du
poteau c'est pour ça qu'ils qu'orange
est même très gros et ça va monter tous
les jours un petit peu début de l'été
après sa vaste écrémé mais vont rester à
fond la chasse n'est pas éliminatoire
mais elle pense pour le classement
pratique
à ce titre la france a pris aujourd'hui
un excellent départ on voit c'est une
discipline vraiment impressionnante et
florent hagara l'obstacle en particulier
qu'il a posé pour un jeune cavalier oui
c'est étonnant regardez c'est l'obstacle
numéro 5 qui a causé beaucoup de soucis
à ses concurrents vous voyez ce mur
appelé tous appelés aussi falaises
d'étretat visiblement très compliqué à
négocier et qui va même effrayé
notamment dans la matinée certains
chevaux on le sait le cso c'est une
discipline hyper spectaculaire
on a d'ailleurs assisté
notamment encore ce matin de nombreuses
chutes à l'image de ce cavalier portugal
a lourdement chuté ou de ce concurrent
indien qui lui aussi va se relever sans
dommage la coupe il car c'est
impressionnant ils sont ils sont ils
sont pas ils sont pas en sucre mais il
ya deux favoris un peu d'amis randall le
brésilien qui est tombé yacht vers
l'oeil le belge au stick l'un des people
comme l'a dit très bien madame maigret
la propriétaire de pénélope leprévost je
crois que c'est vraiment la pression
d'un championnat parce que parce que les
chevaux on en sauter des choses comme ça
et partout dans le monde dont l'on sait
vraiment ce pression d'un championnat du
monde sans aucun doute un signe tant
mieux tant mieux pas sûr d'autant plus
fort mais on attend cette semaine les
français il ya une autre discipline dont
on n'a pas encore parlé qui est en
compétition depuis ce matin avec là
aussi des espoirs de médaille c'est la
voltige florent et ça se passe au zénith
de fonds va voir ça contrairement aux
apparences ce n'est pas du cirque ce
n'est pas non plus de la gymnastique
c'est donc de la voltige et ça commence
par le programme imposé par équipes des
équipes mixtes
il faut le préciser vous voyez sur ces
images les français dans leurs habits de
lumière les uns après les autres ces
cavaliers gymnastes enchaîne des figures
sur le même cheval c'est très joli
c'est assez spectaculaire et les
français rêvent pourquoi pas de
décrocher une médaille ils sont pour
l'instant quatrième par équipes de ce
programme imposé presque on détruire
surtout bien ce qu'il fasse des
étincelles en individuel mais on a dix
huit belles et tous les espoirs
tricolores reposent sur cet homme là ça
s'est passé il ya quelques minutes
seulement au zénith de caen le français
nicolas andréani numéro 1 mondial et
grand favori de cette épreuve
individuelle c'est la grande star de la
voltige
nicolas andréani qui va tenter de
décrocher une deuxième médaille pour
cette équipe de france d'équitation
il est pour l'instant deuxième du
classement provisoire qui est dominé par
un autre français
ferrari
surtout les deux premiers losilla 1er 2e
vois pas ce que ça peu être deuxième
l'autre premier donc ça il ya une vraie
bagarre entre les deux c'est génial
bonne nouvelle merci il ya une grosse
grosse grosse pression et puis
effectivement c'est relativement serré
dans cette compétition également un ca
c'etait le programme de figures imposées
dans le programme libre
nicolas andréani est très très fort il a
une tête et un mental vraiment vraiment
magnifique pour la voir on va continuer
à parler de voltige on va aller sur le
village des jeux parce qu'il ya aussi
vous le savez des animations depuis la
semaine dernière consacrée aux pour le
public en tout cas on va retrouver en
direct depuis village de florine et bas
et oui on va parler de voltige éducative
avec georges cauterets qui est à mes
côtés homme de cheval depuis 40 ans
bonsoir bonsoir à vous diriger une
académie de voltige équestre qui n'a
rien à voir avec la voltige de
compétition alors pourquoi on vient chez
vous qu'est ce qu'on y trouve
alors les enfants parce que c'est
destiné aux enfants je suis à côté de
deauville à oberwil et j'accueille les
enfants en internat est en stage je vis
jours et là je leur fais découvrir la
veulent faire l'équitation par la
voltige c'est à dire que je donne aux
enfants cette possibilité de découvrir
tout de suite dès la première leçon et
les premiers instants le galop cette
allure qu'ils n'ont ils rêvent mais
qu'ils apprennent également quand il
démarre également ça les aide à affirmer
leur personnalité a complètement que
vous avez c'est un sport de toute façon
faisait qui demande beaucoup de
d'humilité car c'est le seul sport vous
êtes confrontés à quelque chose de
vivant
c'est également destinée aux scolaires
on peut faire une année un peu à part
chez vous je pourrais tu dis oui mais
j'ai trois disciplines j'ai la voltige
pour l'expression corporelle et la
confiance dans le physique ensuite
l'expression théâtrale j'ai un théâtre
avec des cours de théâtre et pour le
plaisir parce que maintenant ce sont des
centenaires qui naissent maintenant qui
me sont confiées les futurs centenaire
donc la nourriture est important donc
école de cuisine en même temps merci
georges
je vous rappelle que si vous voulez voir
des démonstrations de voltige équestre
georges cauterets et sur la carrière des
démonstrations quatre fois par jour
jusqu'à dimanche et qu'il fait également
des baptêmes gratuits
merci beaucoup beaucoup florine c'est
vraiment l'occasion de rencontrer
une légende oui tout à fait mais genre
depuis depuis 40 ans il a dû mettre des
dizaines de milliers d'enfants à cheval
avec le salon du cheval à paris avec ce
qu'il fait de toute l'année chez lui
près de deauville je crois que si le
sport équestre et le 2e ou 3e fort
pratique et maintenant on doit beaucoup
à cet homme là bravo lui ont pas vu la
semaine dernière avec le concours
complet les montures normandes sont au
rendez vous de ces jeux ils aiment bien
sûr pour le concours de saut d'obstacles
en coulisse bien sûr il ya les éleveurs
les propriétaires et parmi eux
geneviève mais gannett propriétaire
notamment de la jument de pénélope
leprévost sur ces jeux équestres une
rencontre signée catherine bérard et
patrick merde chez les maigret le cheval
est depuis une affaire de famille une
passion commune alors lorsque je ne
viens va lâcher la médecine qu'il
exerçait depuis 25 ans en région
parisienne pour se lancer dans l'élevage
c'est tout naturellement que son mari et
sa fille l'ont suivi on arrivera
toujours énormément soutenu et sur ce
point financièrement parce que c'était
quand même aussi important j'ai dit
adieu à la médecine j'ai vendu ma
clientèle pour me consacrer
exclusivement
au choix
c'est vrai que ma passion c'est les
chevaux de jambi donc même si
vraisemblablement élever des chevaux pur
sang serait peut-être plus lucratifs
quelque part
j'ai besoin mois du contact avec
avec mes chevaux de les monter et
éventuellement de
de les avoir un certain temps autour de
moi est bon ça ça n'existe pas tellement
dans les dents les chevaux de course les
maigret ont fait l'acquisition du haras
de clarbec en 88
ils viennent de s'agrandir avec la
poterie située à tourgéville c'est là
que l'activité de l'élevage été
transféré pour les jeunes chevaux ils
grandissent tranquillement jusqu'à leurs
quatre ans avec un débours âge à deux
ans en attendant de devenir un jour ou
pas des bêtes de concours le bon cheval
c'est le qui fait bien ce qu'il sait
faire après bon ben si on a la chance de
les lever des gagnants des gagnants
groupe ou si nous on a de la chance
d'élever des chevaux de haut niveau
c'est formidable mais déjà c'est est
important c'est qu'un cheval fasse bien
à son niveau
12 polinière cinq étalons neufs chevaux
de grand prix
c'est le fond de couverts de geneviève
mégret qui couvre ainsi toute la filière
du cheval de sport de l'élevage à la
compétition de très haut niveau en
passant par la formation des jeunes
chevaux le commerce et l'étalonnage au
départ il n'était pas forcément question
délai si haut dans la performance
nahyane a monté depuis quatre ans par
pénélope leprévost a entraîné plus le
monde dans son sillage
et c'est vrai que le haut niveau c'est
il c'est grisant alors y'a pas que des
bons côtés toujours mais c'est vrai que
c'est assez c'est assez
à ce niveau là ce qui est sympathique
c'est le partager
c'est le partage de voilà des joies des
peines aussi parfois mais c'était voilà
chacun donner quelque chose à l'eau pour
obtenir un résultat n'est pas
aujourd'hui que compris les terres mais
c'est vrai que c'est un métier et qu'il
faut avoir les reins solides car quand
on est propriétaire de chevaux de sport
il faut s'attendre à dépenser beaucoup
d'argent sans forcément en gagner un
risque financier et humain nécessaire
cependant car en france on n'a pas
encore trouvé d'autres moyens pour
soutenir l'équitation de haut niveau
voilà pour ce beau portrait on va
maintenant avec vous florent faire le
point sur les épreuves de demain p et ça
commence à 9h10 au stade michel d'ornano
avec la suite des épreuves de cso
qualification en équipe et en individuel
et puis à 9 heures 30 direction le
zénith de caen pour les programmes ligue
2 de libre de voltige féminin masculin
et par équipes et sylvain jolie chemise
rose vous avez toutes vos chances
je crois que j'ai toutes mes chances
effectivement dréjac tête 1re sur le
programme de demain sur l'ailé les
moments ford à partir de demain que sur
un seul obstacle devant s'effectuer les
grosses sélections puisque tout le monde
peut repartir demain même ceux qui ont
eu des mésaventures qui sont tombés qui
sont éliminés je repartis avec un gros
handicap
surtout s'il court pour leur équipe mais
à partir de demain soir on ne gardera
pour après demain que les dix meilleures
équipes et les 50 meilleurs à d'huile de
long 50 chansons 53 ou est ce que je
veux dire mon cas
les deux tiers qui vont qui vont
terminer la compétition demain
merci henri jacques c'est bien c'est
bien compris maintenant on va simplement
faire un petit rappel très important
pour tous les téléspectateurs vous
pouvez nous retrouver sur internet
puisque notre rédaction web est mobilisé
pour ces jeux équestres mondiaux
bastille rain man 10 points france 3
point fr avec notamment un article sur
les épreuves d'attelage l'équipe de
france qui a passé ces derniers jours à
lisieux et bien qui a effectué un stage
préparatoire derniers réglages et gros
espoirs
on passe maintenant à notre chronique
quotidienne de mathieu bellingen les
pieds dans le crottin une chronique qui
n'a jamais aussi bien porté son nom
une chose dont on ne parle pas assez aux
jeux équestres mondiaux ce sont les
mathématiques
sachant qu'un cheval et entre 10 et 20
crottin par jour combien d'horticulteurs
vous trouver leur bonheur ici bonjour
monsieur vous allez bien gérer vous même
très bien alors j'ai du crottin de
cheval tout frais oui qu'est ce qu'on
pouvait en faire mettre ça dans mon
composteur pour le mans qui mélange avec
eux ce que j'ai ça va ça va se marier
ensemble ça va me faire un bon fumier à
l'aide
on dit que ça vaut de l'or ça se conclut
mme y est alors vous monsieur vous vous
avez travaillé à la ferme avec des
chevaux des choses et époque là on
faisait aussi du fumier avec le crottin
de cheval toujours pourquoi c'est pour
faire lui même ou chantent pour sa croix
publié une perte de parts david juste
heureuse puisque c'est bénéfique pour
peut le jeter sans gaspiller très
bénéfique apparemment des rues
merci monsieur commande ou et au revoir
je ne sais pas ce qu'il est dans le
creux tas mais c'est un engrais deux
compétitions
voilà et pour terminer une image une
photo celle d'une rock star que vous
connaissez tous mick jagger il a annoncé
qu'il serait présent pour les 40 ans du
festival américain de deauville
il viendra présenter en avant première
le 12 septembre son film get enough dont
il est le producteur consacré à james
brown
un festival qui débute vendredi pour dix
jours et la niche du bien ça vous
inspire
satis à chennai fallu le retour mais
labour est un mais vous aimez vous
jagger ans j'adore je préfère michèle
torr pas de ville emmène moi adore
discuter sur tout et n'importe quoi
voilà un festival que nous suivrons bien
sûr merci beaucoup et emmanuel merci
florent merci andré jacques merci
d'avoir participé à cette édition merci
aussi aux équipes techniques et bien
qu'il toute cette journée ont permis la
réalisation du 12/13 et du 19/20 demain
pour le 12/13 vous retrouverez erwan 2
milliards pour le 19/20 vous retrouverez
emilie flahaut
merci de votre attention excellente
soirée à toutes et à tous
mais
à